now every time i'm looking at you i'm  seeing in your head if you're editing  out something we're saying i'm seeing if  you think what i'm saying is not good or  good tell me if you can tell i think  it's your smile and your eyes because  when you laugh you're going to keep that  in  that's that famous anthony laugh oh  don't scare me now um so  so  you're trying to get me off track i'm  gonna try my best just get a close-up on  that name yeah yeah yeah what does that  mean i just don't know if anybody's ever  touched your knee during an interview uh  you may be the first there you go not  gonna be the last now it's a thing  hashtag touch anthony please know